[Musique]
en plein centre de paris dans le
quartier populaire de l'hôtel de vide
entre les allées le marais s'élèvera en
1975 le centre d'art contemporain
finances architecture de métal et de
verre qui regroupera l'ensemble des
activités culturelles et artistiques
ce quartier populaire deviendra demain
le rendez vous des artistes
pourquoi avoir choisi le plateau
beaubourg monsieur robert bordage répond
depuis des générations les français
construisent alors de plus en plus à
l'ouest de paris
on a assisté à cette migration de la fin
19ème siècle est tout au cours du 20e
siècle
si bien que tous les beaux bâtiments
s'inscrivent maintenant autour de
l'étoile et plus loin maintenant vers la
défense le résultat ce que j'avais un
véritable divorce entre les beaux
quartiers les veaux faubourg populaire
et que vous n'avez pas cette unité qui
est absolument nécessaire dans une ville
idées dominantes relier les beaux
quartiers au faubourg populaire à
l'issue d'un concours qui a vu la
participation de près de 500 architectes
venus du monde entier
c'est le projet d'un groupe italien
thierno en rodgers le voici qui a été
retenue par le jeu ce projet se présente
comme une immense boîte de verre sur
pilotis longue de 130 m autre de 46
originalité de cette architecture
futuriste les cloisons mobiles
permettront toutes sortes de
transformation selon les besoins
l'audiovisuel aura une place de choix
puisqu'une grande partie de la façade
pour être utilisé comme écran de
projection
[Musique]
la première chose qu on associe des
faits c'était le faire justement puis
qu'un bâtiment un système vous savez
quelque chose très libre de se rénover
de s'échanger avec les citations avec
les temps pour sal ce bâtiment c'est
exactement peut-être au moins c'est dans
l'intelligence et acte mal comme ça d'un
monument ce bâtiment nous apparaît comme
marquant une étape dans la construction
actuelle c'était pour nous essentiel
nous sommes trouvés devant s'ils sont 80
projets approximativement sonde révèle
et nous sommes découvert très vite
allergique au grand geste architectural
la simplicité 20-6 vous pensez que ce
bâtiment sera disons le témoin de son
époque
oui nous espérons d'ailleurs nous avons
découvert une chose en connaissant les
l'auteur et on les voyant surtout c'est
y sont jeunes
déjà c'est important ça ne veux beaucoup
[Musique]